the continuing tensions between russia
and the u.s are raising concerns about
the future of the international space
station moscow now says it intends to
withdraw from the project after 2024.
nasa and other international partners
may want to keep the station in orbit
until 2030 but without the russians that
may not be possible mark strassman is
outside the kennedy space center mark
where does nasa go from here
hey fly good morning no question the
russians caught nasa off guard with this
announcement which came without warning
and still without official confirmation
to the u.s base agency
it's odd behavior given the fact that
the russians have been nasa's major
international space partner for the last
quarter
century already orbiting on borrowed
time the iss could have its longevity
shortened further by this announcement
from moscow yuri borisov russia's new
space director tells president vladimir
putin
the decision to leave the station after
2024 has been made so russia can begin
building its own space station putin's
response
good do you want the relationship to end
no absolutely not robin gaytons nasa's
iss director taken by surprise at a
conference we haven't received any
official word from the from the partner
as as to
the news today and
so we'll be talking more about their
plan going forward also caught off guard
the u.s state department it's an
unfortunate development given the
critical scientific work performed at
the iss
up in space the iss crew currently
includes an italian three russians three
americans the rotating commander a
russian cosmonaut oleg artemyv nasa
astronaut chell lingeren's reaction we
haven't heard anything officially
of course you know we were trained to do
a mission up here and and that mission
is one that requires
the whole crew on the iss the russian
segment provides all propulsion
controlling the station's altitude the
u.s controls orientation and provides
satellite communication and solar power
cosmonauts and astronauts work together
but operate their respective segments
even during difficult moments like the
war in ukraine and this announcement
from moscow here's what lindgren told us
back in march the only way that we can
succeed
is if we all as a crew work together how
do you keep that level of
professionalism when there are issues
happening 250 miles below our lives
depend on them their lives depend on us
among the unanswered questions what's
the exact timeline of the russian
pull-out is moscow serious about it and
could the u.s and its partners somehow
keep the iss operating without its
critical russian partners i asked nasa
administrator bill nelson about this
possibility back in march
what is the contingency plan well we
know that we can continue it for the
short term and we'd have to do other
things and those contingency plans are
already there
but the specifics of those contingency
plans are unclear and there's absolutely
no question that keeping the iss in
orbit without russian help would become
a whole lot more challenging
nate
mark thank you